hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're gonna
be going over one of my favourite game
it's this low [ __ ] game it derives from
the Philidor defense which is pawnee for
upon e 5 Knight to f3 one of my more
common openings i like to play and then
pawn d6 from black this is the Philidor
defense it's extremely passive i don't
like playing against it too much
so i try to find ways to play some spicy
gambits to catch my opponent off of
guard the main line is to continue with
pawn to d4 they could always capture
here but one of the more common moves is
Knight to f6 and from here I like to
move Knight to g5 the black can continue
with Bishop to e7 or many times I'm
seeing pawn to h6 forcing the knight to
move because they don't expect the
knight to come up here in game but with
a little [ __ ] gambit of Knight takes f7
this is forking the Queen and of the
rook pretty much the king is gonna be
taking here if they want to give you a
queen or rook for free hey that's
completely fine but more than likely
they're gonna be taking with their King
here on f7 now once they do that's then
upon to e5 is going to be the play now
they can't just take with their pawn the
Queen is going to false and that is not
an option here
so after the pon takes on e5 a lot of
ways that black can't continue and
that's what we're gonna be looking at
today in our video now the most common
line from black is to play Knight to d7
you can already see that the board is
wide open for white to attack here but
the knight comes back since was under
attack and is now attacking this pawn
here on e5 the move from here is going
to be Bishop to c4 when you have an
opponent's King and it's out in the
middle for you to attack you have to
engage as many pieces as possible to
really give yourself the strongest
attack there's a few options that they
have here one of them would be pawn to
d5 now it could be tempting to go ahead
and take with your Bishop here on d5 I'm
gonna say that's not the best move what
really is the best move is pawn to
ecigs now this looks like well they just
go ahead and take that pawn here but
they really can't if the King takes here
then the Queen's gonna come up here and
it is going to be checkmates don't have
too many moves here King to f6 and then
this is going to be mate if they don't
do that let's say after pawn to e6 they
just come back to g8 okay well that's
fine we can go ahead and gobble up that
night here and now there's gonna be a
discovered attack if they want to go
ahead and take with their pawn right
here then Queen up here d5 this is check
as well maybe King to h7 Queen to f5
check you can see things are not going
well at all
pawn g6 trying to stop it and this is a
little spicy move here pawn up here
taking on a c8 so capturing your Bishop
you have two queens on board they pretty
much have to to take this coin here and
as soon as they take the Queen can come
up and capture why it's gonna be in a
dominant position now if we come back
and after the move pawn six if they play
King to e7 another logical line that
they have here then we're gonna play
pawn takes on d7 same as before let's
say they take with their Queen go ahead
and take with your pawn this is gonna be
completely fine you can get your Queen
involved into the game if you want to
you can castle on the King side at
Knight to c3 you can the King is just
ready to be attacked so this is gonna be
a very good variation now if we come
back instead of the pawn coming here to
d5 because we already saw that probably
not the best move the best move for them
would actually be King to g6 but it
looks extremely scary as far as why
would you just bring your King here even
more out into the open but this would be
the best move from here paani six as we
talked about before they're usually
gonna be moving their knight couple
places one night to be six attacking the
bishop here just bring your bishop back
to b3 you have a really solid structure
this still defends the pawn here on e6
very easy to now get the Queen in ball
to the game if you want to get your
knight involved you could eventually
Cass on the queenside more than likely
you will castle on the kingside if
instead they play knight down here to e5
still attacking the bishop still gonna
recommend bringing the bishop back here
to b3 but now you have more options
later on pawn to f4 really throwing
everything at the king side and
attacking the knight and then you can
castle on the King side as well but
since King to g6 just does not look that
easy another option would be King to e7
now White's going to take the pawn here
on d6 generally if you can take material
and put your opponent in check opening
up the board state when the Kings in the
middle that's going to be very good now
black does need to take with his pawn if
he doesn't it's going to be checkmate so
a couple variations maybe King to H or
to e8 just trying to get that King back
but this is gonna fail Queen to h5 check
you can see that there's just no defense
for this King right here pawn to g6 sure
that just doesn't do much at all this is
going to be checkmate if instead of King
to e8 they try King to f6 still going to
be a victory for whites Queen to f3
check and then Queen up here and at the
end of the day this is going to be a
checkmate
you could have Queen to e6 and this is
going to be checkmate now if we come
back and say the pawn actually does
capture here on d6 as it needs to then
Knight to c3 and the reason this is good
why just has so many options if we look
at blacks standpoint you can already see
the Kings out in the middle the dark
square bishop it can't go anywhere light
square bishop can't go anywhere the
night here on b8 can really only come to
c6 that's not gonna be all that helpful
Knight here to d5 that's gonna be
checked and easily get the other Bishop
involvement of the game the Queen has
full control of the D file in this light
square diagonal so it doesn't matter
where black goes his limited options can
easily be put into check and then also
the pawns can start pushing forward here
for white and even put more pressure
on black so all this is gonna be
extremely good for white likes gonna
have a very difficult time if we come
back instead of the king going to e7
could come back here to e8 but we
already saw a glimpse of this before
Queen to h5 check maybe pawn to g6 queen
up here takes king to e7 and then Queen
to f7 and this is going to be checkmate
so that is what happens with the most
popular line of Knight to d7 not really
fun for black to play but the next one's
going to be the knight takes here on e4
just as I'll try to gobble up material
the best move is Queen to f3 this is
putting their opponent to check
threatening the nights here on f3 a
couple options if it just wants to play
Knight to f6 says I know I'm gonna lose
my knight so I'm gonna go ahead and do
this that's fine pawn takes here on f6
maybe the Queen takes in this case
Bishop to c4 remember Kings out in the
board you need to get more material
involved into the game don't try to do
tricky and just trade off you don't want
to trade down at all
you gave up material so that you can
have a strong attack so don't trade off
Queens here put constant pressure on
your opponent's maybe Queen to e2 here
if they eventually want to do something
decline Bishop to e3 and then this has a
discovered attack so they have to always
keep in mind that if their King is on a
dark square the bishop can always go
there and then there is going to be a
discovered attack with the Queen you can
always castle on the King side you can
get your knight here to c3 start to
attack Castle on the Queen side so a lot
of different options if they don't play
Knight to f6 some people don't like to
bring their Knight if it's under attack
they could play King to g8 thinking it's
going to a safe square just go ahead and
take the material here on e4 same thing
if they play King to g6 which many times
is a good move in this case it's
absolutely not a good move because after
the Queen takes it's putting their
opponent in to check exactly what you
want to do and even worst mistake would
be Bishop here to f5 making it a seem
like okay yeah I want to attack save my
king here but pretty much they're just
giving
the material here on b7 now they could
play Knight to d7 because the rook would
just fall here on a8
but then White has the great move of
pawn to g4 a lot of different threats
this has if the bishop takes the rook
and swing over here to g1 that's going
to pin down the bishop you could even
see something like pawn to h5 but then
pawn to e3 from whites and the bishop
would fall just because it is being
pinned down from the rook you can also
see this dark square bishop putting a
lot of pressure on the opponent you can
always swing the Queen back as well just
no real way for black to defend against
this correctly another variation that
you could see is Knight to EA this is
exactly where you want your opponent to
be headed getting all his pieces back on
the eighth-ranked if you see this Bishop
to c4 we've talked about this before
getting more material involved into the
game one option could be king to g6 if
you see this I recommend pawn to f4
staying extremely aggressive another
option if they play Bishop to e6 this is
gonna be extremely good for whites
because you just play Queen to h5 check
and then after pawn to g6 then the
bishop takes check and once the King
takes then you could take this pawn here
on g6 check Queen here to f5 check and
you can see after pawn to e6 just a very
good board state from white can easily
swing over here to a d5 can get the
knight involved into the game definitely
not where black wants to be the last
option that you may see is the pawn take
here on e5 now many players that they
haven't played this variation don't do
this because they recognize that the
queen is going to take here on d8 they
actually do have a move and that is
Bishop to b4 check because the rook and
I'll take here on d8 after the check so
it's a discovered attack so because of
this knowing
queen is going to fall the best move is
to bring the Queen back here to d2 the
bishop has to take can't be down a queen
so after the bishop takes you want to
take with your knight the reason is you
want to hold on to this material here on
e4 so white is up a material has a
better board States and so all in all
this is still gonna be a very very good
game from white so that's a local game
it hopefully you guys and enjoy this
video one of my favorite game bits and
definitely like to punish someone for
playing a very passive defense this has
so many tricky lines if someone has not
played it as black and it's a lot of fun
just to chase your opponent's King
around so leave a comment let me know
what you guys think if you have other
videos you want me to make feel free to
send me an email let me know always
looking for suggestions but until next
time thanks again for watching I'll see
you guys then